bonsoir dao traxel vous êtes donc vous
êtes donc la vie secrète des chirac il
ya un air de ressemblance indéniable
quand on vous voit salle et thierry savy
et vous racontez votre incroyable destin
dans un livre intitulé la fille de kurt
chez flammarion voilà alors vous êtes né
au vietnam au sud de seuils gants dans
une famille bourgeoise père directeur
d'école maison de fonction chauffeur
domestique c'était ça allez pour vous
quoi c'est sympa c'est sympa alors à
l'époque le vietnam est coupée en deux
au succès les américains qui ont
remplacé les français votre père colabor
on peut dire avec les américains tout à
fait votre mère elle c'est plutôt la
france
oui c'est paris match et la valise elle
aussi ce que la france a menacé la
france
complètement ouais ouais vous rêvait
d'épouser un français vaut mais comment
vous avez fini par le faire c'est
prémonitoire tout à fait c'est emmanuel
et des coucous chéri elle est juste
derrière moi même pas lasser
on va fermer un manuel et mal
[Musique]
en asie
et la misère
à chaque coup
emmanuel merci terrible parce que quand
elle était petite elle rêvait d'épouser
un français et après toute cette
aventure qu'on m'a raconté qui est
absolument incroyable
elle a fini par épouser un français et
il est plutôt beau garçon votre emmanuel
beau il est très beau hein
tous d'accord mais torse nu c'est encore
mieux
c'est bien
je me fais appeler le roi la princesse
voilà exactement
absolument et j'étais maître nageur et
aujourd'hui le nombre de vies que j'ai
sauvée en mer vous permet de dire je
suis toujours fier d'être maître nageur
t'es pas content on était bien
enfin c'est quand même le gendre à papa
qu'on dit dont il est bien celui là
bon reste avec nous alors très bien
c'est vraiment moche sur ça donc on est
et on en était au vietnam de l'époque
donc le sud avec les américains qui ont
remplacé les français et le nord
évidemment le nord vietnam soutenu par
la chine de mao tsé toung voilà le 30
avril 1975 c'est la prise du palais
présidentiel donc à saigon par les
troupes communistes du nord alors chez
vous à ce moment là c'est la panique
on se débarrasse de tout ce qui peut
rappeler les américains donc on enlève
des étiquettes sur les bouteilles
côtoient tout eric c'est juste pas le
nom mon frère le dernière là qu'ils
appellent mais ça veut dire américain on
a obligé comme le mans a personne à
m'aider mais personne pour appeler mon
frère par le prénom faut changer on
l'appelait tout simplement le dernier
c'est tout maintenant voilà alors ce qui
est plus grave c'est qu'on envoie votre
père dans un camp de rééducation donc
est violemment quoi ils viennent le
chercher un matin ils lui disent suit
nous on ne colle une balle dans la tête
quoi c'est traduire cette image là et
quand je quittais pour la dernière fois
qu'on l'a transformé mon père
complètement s'est détruit quoi l'image
c'est réparé grèce en moi depuis mais
bon c'est d'ailleurs ce que c'est ce que
j'aime bien dans votre bouquin c'est au
delà de ce qui vous est arrivé avec
jacques chirac
je trouve que c'est un très bon
témoignage sur le vietnam sur cette
époque finalement vu par quelqu'un qui
est encore petit mais mais c'est très
bien vu je trouve c'est très très
intéressant alors quand votre père s'en
va dans ce camp de rééducation chez vous
c'est la misère vous avez plus du tout
de ce groupe de quoi vit
vous êtes obligés de les vendre à la
gare routière au marché des choses que
vous fabriquez à la maison obligé de
transformer votre maison bistrot un
moment oui c'est pour surveiller rit
donc
malheureusement la fierté qu'on met à
côté on est plus penser à la fille de
directeur ou quoi ce soir et on a
dispersé je suis toujours demandé
vraiment volontaire dans la famille je
pars d'un partout pourra essayer de
demander à droite à gauche
dz pour que pour la famille et sur vie
quoi mais on a quand même assez nombreux
dans la famille à peu près et même âge
18 ans 20 ans 22 ans et puis on a
dispersé je leur quitté mon village le
rejoint m'attend mais vraiment c'était
interdit
et vous avez un frère qui sombre dans
l'alcoolisme à ce moment là oui et qui
se livrera sur vous à des actes que vous
avez le courage de raconter finalement
c'est pas facile de parler devant public
c'est vrai j'ai un peu quelque part pas
honte
mais à la place une seule c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile c'est l'aîné
normalement il doit quitter du vietnam
et les pins il est vraiment tort de
rester et finalement il a plongé dans la
drogue
et puis il veut rester à sa fin comme ça
et j'en ne veux pas parce que décédée à
l'âge de 27 ans c'est tout jeune et puis
il a pas d'amour n'a pas pas de femme ni
son amour il est avec des copains et
puis ça finit sa vie c'est quand même
terrible pour lui donc jambe par jean
veut pas aujourd'hui vous lui avez
pardonné
c'est vraiment c'est mon frère quand
même alors ce qui est terrible c'est que
vous n'avez pas le droit d'aller voir
votre père pendant six mois votre mère
finit par y aller
elle y va et elle revient en vous disant
où il en bonne santé il a un peu vieilli
il a un peu maigri mais vous comprenez
que c'est faux mais j'y crois pas ouais
je sais très bien que avec un traitement
je ne sais pas comment il a fait avec
mon père mais transformer mon père à
quelques années complètement détruit le
décret c'est mon palais un vieillard
amant mais créer puis perdu des mêmes
mois il connaît plus personne donc
possible quand vous allez le voir
d'ailleurs vous dites il ressemble à un
mort-vivant accroché j'ai je ne vois
même pas c'était mon père c'est quand
même 25 personnes il se présente c'est
pas qui il était mon père quand même
mais ma place à ce moment-là j'ai
tellement eu après j'ai juste une taie
tous les chefs de deux camps le
surveiller le camp j'ai dû mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait monter le dit
bande de [ __ ] mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est plus fort que vous c'est l'amour
entre père et fille et comme en plus je
sentis et quand même c'est sa fille de
fin paraît qu est-ce qui passaient
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait mon père sait si
j'en veux tout le monde entier en plus
j'ai obligé quitté cessa problème ils ne
savaient pas je crois pas mais moi je
sais j'adore les laisser voilà alors un
jour vous entendez parler des boat
people qui filent vietnam vous commencez
à économiser de l'argent pour pour
acheter votre passage sur ce bateau
alors vous dites en parlant du bateau
une expression très très jolie et très
typique en tous les cas vous dites on
était plus serré que des grains de riz
dans un bol mais tout à fait passer
outre rendez compte
j'ai bon
je les sables pour que blake et mais
quelque part on a entassé quand même 3
125 passagers sur un bateau de 10 mètres
longueur et que s'ils mettent l'argent
et on a des étages les enfants au fond
et les femmes au premier étage et moi
j'ai déjà pas question que je restais
avec les femmes
je suis garçon manqué je veux absolument
rester au bord même avec les gars on
savait rien de toute façon je pense pas
une seconde vie peut pas me faire quoi
ce soir et finalement je restais avec
les garçons mais il ya des enfants qui
mouraient dans les cales lma temps
monter des enfants tous à pied autour du
bateau c'est la mer de chine autour du
lac tianchi qui tournait enfin c'est
vraiment un exode absolument
extraordinaire que vous avez vécu mais
là vous arrivez en malaisie dans l'île
de poules hobby dong et là c'est encore
pire c'est l'enfer parce que d'abord ya
rien à manger ça c'est vrai il n'y a pas
de maison on est obligé de vous
fabriquer des cabanes en bambou au fond
des cons que ge a été vraiment couché
sur un petit mahatma pas combien
considéré comme un matelas mais c'est
des petits pas ton que j'ai fabriqué
avec les sacs
de farine vide et remplir les feuilles
mortes et j'étais couché quand même sept
mois c'est terrible cette île de poules
au bidon parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
de sécurité n'y a pas de crime ya quand
même beaucoup de viol
je l'avais dit que la nuit on entendait
des hommes des femmes se faire violer
c'est vrai mais problème c'est que entre
nous que c'est ça c'est laid
les réfugiés entre eux et on n'a rien à
dire chacun pour soi alors vous attendez
votre départ en france vous postulez
pour venir ici
c'est l'époque où arrive le bateau l'île
de lumière de bernard kouchner mais je
suis très content parce que j'ai lu
bernard kouchner hier j'ai eu le
téléphone ça mais tellement faciaux près
j'ai tellement heureux de parler
directement avec bernard kouchner et que
je les ai expliqué pourquoi je n'ai pas
de contacts et depuis 20 ans serait le
temps passe et finalement j'ai rend
hommage directement et je souhaitais de
leur vol le plus tôt possible parce que
c'est c'est bernard kouchner c'est quand
même quelqu'un vraiment deux cas c'est
un de sauveur de tous les réfugiés
vietnamiens ce poc là avec l'équipe
les médecins sans fontières nation alors
le 18 juillet 1979
c'est le départ pour paris oui dans un
avion affrété par la mairie de paris
faisait 22 ans et à l'arrivée à orly
vous vous écroulez dans un coin vous
pleurez à gros sanglots
et c'est là que jacques chirac bout
remarques
sinon oui syrie parce que c'est énorme
on est on est content on est heureux
parce que ça ça donne sens soulagé
vraiment on a quitté quand même l'hymne
de l'oppidum
mais la peur totale et j'ai tellement
peur de l'avenir
qu'est-ce que je deviens qu'est ce que
je fais avec ma nouvelle vie que je
parle pas à mon français se moquent là
et je suis vraiment je suis seule et
vraie manson et épais jeu sans tir
lointain mes parents est perdus c'est
pour ça je restais donc qui comptera
vraiment pour pleurer et peut penser à
mes parents ce moment là et puis tout
d'un coup quelqu'un qui vient vers moi
quand je me lève ma tête mais je vois un
grand blanc parce que moi je ne sais pas
c'est une france et où c'est quoi j'en
sais rien j'ai vu un grand blanc avec
une canne parce que ce poquelin il est
encore une assise dans deux voitures a
longtemps ils en gagnent et que j'ai
apprête à côté moi donc il parlait
parlait je comprends rien et petits
boutons mouchoirs il m'aider mais
d'après avec le prête depuis longtemps
lui quand même deux
deux noms ont deux prénoms je n'en sais
rien laurence et claude oui je sais pas
quoi encore laurent schott non pas pour
moi c'est le nom quoi et finalement le
prédit mais ma petite tu te rends compte
c'est que le maire de paris n'est dit
mais désormais je pleure plus de ma
chérie tout ça a comme la troisième
fille je vais accueillir dans notre ami
avec mes deux filles laurence et claude
mais j'ai je ne sais pas je comprends
rien et surtout je n'ai pas réalisé mais
à travers de ces regards tirez vous me
croyez pas qu'on aimerait peut-être
aussi mis une fois la scène
on le sentait quelque chose entre moi et
lui sait quelque chose d'assurance on
lui a posé la question le dit pourquoi
vous avez choisi cette petite fille l'a
dit parce qu'elle pleurait c'était la
seule qui pleurait dont je me suis
approché de lui et puis 10 secondes pour
décider
il neige est pareil donc ceseda pas le
coeur que tend la main à ckoi lantiéri
alors là vous commencez à vivre avec les
chirac alors à paris a entendu à la à
l'hôtel de ville mais aussi au château
de bity en corrèze où fait connaissance
avec vincent lindon
l'époque est l'ami de sympa il n'est pas
très très très beau mais là le charme
elle n'avait pas tout et puis plus
triste l'autre fille de jacques chirac
laurence wii qui est anorexique ou
assister à des scènes c'est difficile à
table quand elle veut pas manger quoi
oui son père s'énerve et c'est compliqué
quoi je trouvais qu'elle et elle a assez
mer et que j'ai l'impression de les
félins bien un vrai c'est m pourquoi là
comme boucliers ou à la sens bien ma
peau mais quelque part à la table c'est
sûr qu'elle ment très peu et puis je
respect j'ai beaucoup de respect pour un
sabotage et le mans des épargné non plus
alors jacques chirac est un père très
attentif pour henry il vous aide à
préparer vos affaires pour la rentrée
des classes il est dans des camps oui
j'ai comme un 22 ans il m'a préparé le
carter
tu me passes un cartable ou randall
temps après bien sûr laurent l1 plein
elle a pris un retard tapie dit quelque
chose de bien à laurent n'est pas au
filet ce qui est d'ailleurs un peu
abîmée et puis finalement le club des
crayons tout ça et puis finalement
l'idée tient malgré tout est prêt et je
percevais avec ton karatay tu fasses en
sortait très bien d'envoyer la preuve
alors il qu'ils effectuent parce que
quand il dit au revoir à ses filles leur
met un baiser sur chaque peut pas
mélanger les merveilleux merveilleux
c'est tous les sens on a l'impression
n'est là les tropiques cochon qui
viendra en devient vraiment petit enfin
je me sens vraiment pas 22 ans ne sont
pas minces mais pas disant tiens
renoncer ont mené b vous sentez pas un
peu la princesse non je me sentais
vraiment comme aller vraiment pas passée
à bien ses raids les mains et pieds vol
de bonnes nuits attendant tendrement
merville il ya un truc c'est que le soir
bon bernadette on sait pas très bien ce
qu'elle fait
les imams elle a toujours quelques jours
a même amené à la facebook
alan jackson vont voir la télé donc
c'est à dire que les filles vont voir la
télé dans dans d'autres pièces et vous
vous tapez les westerns et que jacques
chirac le soir mais le problème c'est
pas que je ça m'intéresse de shanwei
pascal terry lloyd leader femme quand
même de l'acteur préféré de mon père
mais voudront des cons parce que j'ai
quand même il priera dg je reste avec
mon père à côté je comprends rien dit
mais est ce que ton roi j'ai dit oui
mais enfin j'ai rien compris c'est pas
grave parce que je reste avec mon père
je les ai moment merveilleux cccc
chaleureux voilà alors finalement vous
prévenir votre famille biologique en
france
enfin on peut remarquer un truc en tous
les cas c'est que moi j'étais très
étonné de voir ça il n'y a pas tellement
de passe droit
regardez comme ils ont avec ma lantiéri
moi j'ai pas très très très bien mais
des non plus
en fait j'ai fait un des marques comme
tout le monde finalement fallait attend
tous les ordres le renouvellement de
l'eau siée puis pendant le tampa bay
s'est fait doubler en fait tes parents
sont arrivés
c'est trop tôt c'est m'a dit ça ça a
pris du temps
et puis après on va vous raconter votre
vie votre vie amoureuse 1 jusqu'à
emmanuel ça l'homme de ma vie
racontez-nous comment vous l'avez
rencontrée en dos ben je rencontrais en
fait j'ai passé vingt quand un cap
d'agde
donc oui qu'est-ce qui patrice cattaert
de paroles cordiales cc c'est un endroit
pour les échangistes s'agisse s'échange
service
emmanuel caussé les gens qui sont tous
ensemble cap d'agde non à ben alors là
après quelque chose enfin moi je reviens
à la salle derrière domine out j'ai vu
qu'un trait de sauver quelqu'un vous
voyez gpc bouche à bouche au cap d'agde
conclu avec l'allemagne a commencé
donc bien sûr je suis jaloux j'ai
tellement jamais à la place de la
personne bien sûr mais bon donc moi
c'est un héros est là avant tout
certaines mairies boeing
tout à fait mais là c'est rennes parce
qu'elle était très sérieux dont le nom
du travail pg demain il est grand torse
nu super alors la gare yamna didier rey
parce qu'à 20 sur 20
[Musique]
ces flamands
alors une question que je me pose moi
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes pas
demandé la permission à jacques chirac
et à bernadette chirac pour faire ce
livre mérite ou mais vous êtes tous mes
parcours tirer c'est quand même
douloureux
ouais le souffrent et surtout je parlais
à personne depuis vingt six ans même pas
mon ex oui c'est très discrète en fait
je voudrais garder c'est quand même mon
histoire un mois c'est pas facile
d'expliquer ça avec mon frère et puis ma
main ne sais pas si mes enfants ni mon
excellent moment vous pensez que si vous
aviez demandé la permission à jacques
chirac de faire ce livre il aurait pu
vous dire non c'est pour ça que vous
n'avez pas demandé de tout pas de tout
je sais très bien comment ils me donnent
éducation même arrêt je sais comment il
est ils sont avec moi un bon
personnellement je demande je ne mens
pas à toute façon il me laissait libre
de écrit mais même moins bien sûr et
puis bon le souffrent et puis de
remerciement
donc ça fait 26 ans c'est pas trop tôt
c'est le seul moyen pour le remerciement
mes parents dati face à eux sinon je
sais pas si c'est très bon pour lui
sinon je suis pas la matière il passe
pour un type formidable
vraiment il est formidable mon père en
tant que père de coeur alors
contrairement à mme azari vous n'avez
pas été cachés vous visible tout une
fille secrète que cacher justement
pourquoi ça sort seulement maintenant ça
fait peur mais pas ceux que j'ai vus par
la télé de l'histoire de pop ippon mais
ça revient je pleurais devant la tête et
les aimons [ __ ] mais à temps et si tu
es tout et tout et années passées il
faut que tu es traité mais moi documents
comme un pouce et de négocier et à la
burqa jacques chirac vous ait jamais
adopté et parce que mes parents ils sont
vivants d'accord thierry est d'accord
une envie
vous les voyez souvent là maintenant oui
la derniers temps la dernière fois
c'était noël l'art de noël je la mène ma
petite fille cassandre pas si on a une
coupe recomposée n'a pas donc on met
quatre enfants maintenant ensemble et
longtemps très bien et merveilleusement
begel amène la petite casse en tout bon
fan art de noël et chirac vous croyez
qu'il va se représenter en 2007 bon mois
ci en tant personnellement en tant que
sa fille rivasi bat pas mais c'est pas
le cas c'est mon père ces chercheurs à
un moment voulu et puis c'est lui qui va
décider vaut lui même et vous pensez
quoi au fond au fond de moi même comme
amel est toujours beau mâle pas qu'est
ce qui fait sens la politique mame n est
pas l ai pas tort c'est vrai si vous
deviez choisir entre villepin et sarkozy
vous prendriez clivot moi j'apprends
lead à vous lui en voulez de rien at
chirac rien du tout vous avez rien à lui
reprocher mais non on va voir comment on
va faire une interview gratitude
qu'est ce qui vous énerve parfois chez
votre père quand on n'est pas content
qu'un qu'autre chose
il s'énerve facilement s'énerve
facilement ouais c'est le seul défaut
oui seul défaut
ouais tu vois pas autre chose qu'est ce
qui fait le plus mal dans la vie mon
père ouais rien bon et bien le truc qui
fait mal mais non je vois pas si j'ai
vécu avec mon père du joueur qui joue
que de bonnes oeuvres pas du mal le ccnr
pas sainement mais c'est tout il ya bien
des choses qui n'arrivent pas à faire
comme peut-être pris de kolaka cochon
ouais mais pas je vois mal qu'est ce qui
arrive est mauvais bricoleur ben oui je
pense ouais qu'est-ce qui l'a jamais
compris votre père à votre avis jamais
compris quelque chose qui va jamais
compris
mesurez vous poser des questions mais
vraiment on gap alors qu'elle n'y a pas
de réponse serré
hu
[Applaudissements]
très bien bien des choses qu'il n'a
jamais compris quand même dans la vie
non moi je prends une chose qu'elle est
très bien compris que m'a accueilli à
votre avis qu'est ce que mitterrand
avait de plus que votre père rien c'est
comme ça extraordinaire monsieur
mitterrand bien ce bar de respect parce
que monsieur mitterrand est décédé mais
c'est que c'est quelqu'un m'ait vraiment
exemplaire mais mon père aussi quelques
importants voyons il vous a déjà monté
votre père dans la vie il faut monter si
ça fait mal à personne bah oui c'est mon
mari me dit alors ah t'es déjà fait de
telles je n'ai pas fait mais je vais le
faire après mais ça parle qui dit oui
mais c'est qu'on l'a banquiers qu'on a
faits mal à personne
thierry qu'est ce qui n'a jamais su vous
dire votre père il m'a tout dire que des
bonheurs kodesh mais siri vous pouvez
pas vous pouvez pas me demander quoi que
j'ai je peux pas vous donner quoi se
soit tiré
pas un morceau c'est malheureux sacré
personnage mois tout petit déjà été
infernal mais je sais c'est pour ça m'a
épousée tu étais petit
quand j'étais petit au vietnam elle
mangeait que le blanc de poulet tout à
fait ça alors là c'est et character bas
et en dc nous on peut pas manger blanc
poulet bérol battre les larmes
il ya bien des choses où il s'est planté
quand même jacques chirac y à bien il a
bien fait des erreurs quand même
d'autres termes on vous parlait de ça ça
avait professionnels non non ça alors là
il y en a beaucoup et très bon ben alors
ça regarde qu'à lui à vous pensez vous
avez compris trompé j'ai départ j'ai
rien dit c'est vous que madame on a
prêté et tirer alors je dirai jamais ça
moi non mais mon père est maintenant
bien sûr mais ça regarde pas lui qui
assume point final
voilà rien à faire mais non mais moi je
n'ai sa fille est chez nous surtout on
est faut quand même de respect et mon
père parce que si par exemple votre père
il est bonne il est gonflé ou voulait
pas considéré comme votre père
malgré tout s'est envolé comme un repère
bon
et ça marche
dix mois
kelly font
[Musique]
une carte n'est ce pas bon vous devez
nous dire ce que vous supportez le mois
de chez bernadette ben elle nous
surveillent de près des fois c'est vrai
que c'est pour sortir le soir ça
justement parce que des fois je vais
vous raconter quelque chose on était
partis et bon anniversaire on a promis
avec l'autre un pan de jeunes et puis on
est bon allez maman on vient vers minuit
et on était arrivés et les deux heures
et m'amène nous surveille l été et nous
attend au salon était encore réveillée
elle a réveillés et nous attend au salon
et finalement on investit assez chouette
on va enlever des chaussons les marchés
et finalement qu'on est arrivée elle a
allumé un petit bassin à cette heure-ci
couverte d'accord donc le week-end
suivant on n'est plus le sort était un
peu sévère quoi elle est assez sévère
mais c'est pour mon bien tiré j'ai
accepté
[Musique]